[Musique]
mais 1 messieurs bonsoir c'est le jour
même du 50e anniversaire de l'arrivée
d'hitler au pouvoir en allemagne que
l'histoire la plus noire de ce xxème
siècle frappe à nouveau à la porte de
nos souvenirs
en plusieurs occasions nous l'avons vu
tout au long de la semaine et
aujourd'hui plusieurs fantôme s'agite à
nouveau parmi lesquels celui d'un homme
que vous n'avez jamais entendu parler et
qui pour la première fois va s'exprimer
devant une caméra
il s'agit de klaus altmann qui ne nie
plus ce soir avoir été le klaus barbie
qui a arrêté jean moulin mais arrêtez
seulement va nous dire barbie avec un
aplomb très cynique je n'ai appris sa
mort que 20 ans plus tard dans ce
document que nous envoie de la page
jean-claude criton vous allez voir
comment de sa prison bolivienne le
criminel de guerre balaie le passé
comment même ils s'indignent du sort
qu'on lui réserve aujourd'hui
pour rappel qui est menacée une
extradition imminente et vers
l'allemagne est pardon dès à présent
pour la qualité médiocre de l'image
tourner la sauvette et regarder tout
père qui a perdu son fils j'ai perdu mon
fils dé ma femme sur la durée d'un an et
demi et on voit maintenant la télévision
dans des programmes en laiton ou de ma
femme et de mon fils c'est un choc
qu'elle est pour moi un homme nommé
risque mérite pas je ne conçois pas ces
gens je ne vois pas pourquoi ces gens si
peu de respect pour le genre humain pour
la mort et surtout prennent au jeu
dites moi vous mentionnez le respect à
la mort mais dites-moi devriez vous
souvenir des accusations que l'on vous
fait non je sais pas la même chose je
veux parler moi du respect des tombes
tout ce que l'on me ce dont on m'accuse
c'était la guerre dites moi de l'autre
côté est ce qu'on a pas tués aussi oui
bonjour je vous comprends mais c'était
la guerre c'était le maquis
vous savez ici vous en avait fait
l'expérience de la guérilla bon
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait l'armée ici et là
reconnus comme combattants la guérilla
non mais supposons dans le cas des
français qui était en train de défendre
leur patrie
vous considérez que ça c'était une
guerrilla games et bien entendu c'est
une guerre de guérilla c'était un maquis
parce que la france était occupée
elle avait signé un armistice et s'était
engagé à ne pas lutter contre les
allemands c'était donc une convention de
la guerre et les maquisards aller contre
les conventions de genève et de la civil
ne doit pas tuer un homme en uniforme
s'ils ont constitué leur maquis c'était
leur problème mais alors le gouvernement
allemand militaire c'est à dire c'était
l'occupation militaire en france a dû se
défendre
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au
salvador en honduras en afghanistan
dites moi maintenant voici une question
est ce que vous avez eu quelque chose à
voir avec la mort de jean moulin non
avec la mort de jean moulin ans
oui avec sa capture
oui bien entendu non avec sa mort parce
que moi j'ai remis jean mollet j'ai
remis jean-moulin à paris et dites moi
comment il est mort mais je ne sais pas
ce n'est qu'en 1965 ici à la passe dans
une un article de paris match que j'ai
appris la mort de jean moulin
on avait trouvé l'amour
et en lisant l'article de paris match
j'ai appris j'ai appris sa mort sous mes
mains il n'est pas mort de mes mains sur
nos bureaux de très nombreux télégrammes
émanant de tous les horizons politiques
chacun se réjouit de cette victoire sur
le n'oubliez sur l'impunité pour
reprendre les propos du socialiste
georges sarre béate personnel vous avez
l'habitude avec votre mari serge
d'exhumer ce genre d'affaires alors
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
toujours une bonne chose disons de
réveiller les mémoires qui flanche
je crois que c'est une bonne chose que
la lutte que j'ai commencé 11 ans avec
la réouverture du dossier klaus barbie à
munich
et puis j'ai démasqué en bolivie
l'identifier et privé la base de nonda
demain je pense que c'est une bonne
chose parce que cet homme-là s'est
jamais repenti dans les interviews qu'il
avait donnée à la télévision à la radio
ou journaux il s'est félicité d'être
toujours un qui sait tenir hitler il n'a
pas changé d'idée
je crois que c'est une bonne chose que
cet homme-là soient traduits devant la
justice jeudi 40 ans après 7,1
je dirais un procès symbolique qui
montrera le travail de la gestapo en
france à travers lui sera donc montré un
procès historique surtout pour les
jeunes aujourd'hui il faut simplement
nécessaire de montrer comment c'était
possible comme la police politique a pu
bien torturé et tué les résistants mais
aussi c'est très important parce que
barbie a sévit aussi contre les juifs
c'est lui en 44 en avril qui a donné
l'ordre de déporter des petits enfants
juifs de 3,16 en plein boum des enfants
d'izieu et j'étais parti pour une
deuxième fois en bolivie justement pour
mener campagne contre lui c'est d'après
la demande d'extradition de la france et
pour demander bolivienne de l'extrader
et 27 femmes
mme adam hadwin brunet qui a perdu les
trois enfants et son mari et des
fusillés par barbie je crois pour elle
c'est ce sera 10 ont une solution qui
s'impose parce que justice au fait
qu'est ce que vous avez dans aussi et
jaune quitte donc sa sénilité ce klaus
barbie disons qui montre les débuts
comme j'ai commencé à m'occuper de la
sphère klaus barbie ce camp 70 ans le
procureur de munich avait fermé le
dossier quand barbie en disant qu'il n'y
avait pas d évidence pour prouver qu'il
devait connaître le sort des enfants
envoyaient ensuite en 44 et puis un
allemand au moment où justement une
faute de barbie été publiés dans la
presse allemande
un allemand vivant à lima le contacter
en disant je reconnais dans la photo de
barbie de 42 et un homme d'affaires qui
vit entre lima et la passe sous le nom
d' iceman
et puis j'ai réuni en allemagne tous les
documents nécessaires pour identifier
iceman barbie et bien je suis parti en
mali m'a d'abord il a pris la fuite est
allé à la passe est un bolivienne je
n'ai suivi là bas et j'ai convaincu je
crois l'opinion publique et le
gouvernement de l'emporter parce que
vous êtes allemande vous savez la
répercussion que en allemagne et en
france ce procès va avoir vous pensez
que c'est une bonne chose il ne peut pas
y avoir deux chocs en retour
certainement pas et nous avons mené avec
mon mari et des amis
déporté résistant des jeunes vis surtout
nous ont menés en allemagne le procès
contre richard harrison et je dois dire
que nous avons à part des juifs qu'ils
nous ont fait venir chaque fois avec la
location des fils et filles de france
nous avons eu aussi des jeunes
allemandes dans l'art dans la salle des
séances
et puis je me rappelle toujours du
plaidoyer final du juge président du
tribunal qui disait écouter tournée
vanish karan pour moi c'est difficile
aujourd'hui de juger
vu que vous pourrez être mes parents mon
père me taire mon père mais il faut le
faire c'est au nouveau aux nouvelles
générations de fait de condamner les
crimes nazis pour que des choses comme
ça ne puisse pas se reproduire
merci pour votre témoignage
premier titre à la une de l'actualité
donc aujourd'hui klaus barbie criminels
de guerre ancien chef de la gestapo
lyonnaise a passé sa première nuit en
prison au fort montluc de lyon à
l'endroit même choisi symboliquement
d'ailleurs où pendant l'occupation il
fit emprisonner et tué des milliers de
résistants français dont leur chef jean
moulin et déportés près de 7500 juifs
première pièce de notre dossier
aujourd'hui en compagnie nos envoyés
spéciaux isabelle beige clair et michel
lalle lalonde avant revivre les heures
qui ont précédé l'arrivée de klaus
barbie à lyon et son entrée au fort
montluc de lyon tout le monde attendait
le dc-8 militaire qui a mené klaus
barbie en france à l'aéroport de satolas
selon le plan de vol initial
toute la presse des curieux bien sûr
mais aussi d'anciens résistants
socialement 74 à manifester contre
claude darque laisse ouvert
partiellement le cosby bien sûr
quatrième temps du procès vous savez moi
mon point de vue pas grand chose mais
certains surtout qui parle pour des
monstres qui veut redonner la main
est-ce qu'il peut pas avoir fait ce que
1500 déportés et que de nombreux morts
il ya les gens de lyon qui lui ont donné
en masse vers 21h on apprenait que
l'avion s'était finalement posé sur la
base aérienne militaire de corbas dans
la banlieue lyonnaise et on attendait
encore mai au palais de justice cette
fois que klaus barbie soit présentée au
juge d'instruction
mais c'est directement au fort montluc
l'ancienne prison militaire où il avait
lui même interrogé et torturé les
résistants de la région que barbie a été
transportée la carte ération symbolique
dans la présente ses méfaits ne devrait
pas se prolonger plus de quelques jours
en effet le fort montluc est une prison
où ils sont incarcérés que des femmes et
les objecteurs de conscience de toute la
soirée nous n'avons pas aperçu klaus
barbie une seule fois une dessin
personne à l'avoir vu avec le prince est
revenu
ou c'est le bâtonnier qui s'est désigné
d'office trop sa défense en attendant
ses avocats ouest allemand il est il a
fait des déclarations comme la loi les y
autorise
en ce qui concerne la l'inculpation et
la détention
il conteste le chef d'inculpation
comment avez vous trouvé physiquement
comme un homme qui vient de passer trois
jours dans des avions qui a subi le
décalage horaire et qui à connaître 70
ans
[Musique]
l' empire alain vient d'y faire allusion
l'allemagne fédérale avait elle aussi
réclamé l'extradition de klaus barbie
alors pourquoi l' expulsion at-elle été
décidée vers la france il s'agit peut
être là d'un accord politique entre les
deux pays
une correspondance de michel meyer à
bonn qui nous relate d'abord les
réactions de la presse et la manière
dont a été présenté l'événement barbie
c'était en début de soirée hier le
deuxième titre de l'actualité télévisée
mais dans les dernières éditions des
journaux télévisés l'expulsion en france
du bourreau de lyon était passé en
première place largement on explique à
ses culpabilité et ont mis en
perspective l'action de la justice
française pour un côut thèse
correspondant de la télé allemande à
paris le futur procès barbie aura une
signification historique
il montrera ce dont est capable un
système totalitaire par ailleurs très
rapidement une allusion réaction du
gouvernement de bonn la mention qu'une
demande d'extradition avait aussi été
formulée par la rfa dans la presse
écrite gros titre en première page ce
matin des articles qui aurait pu être
écrit à paris ou à lyon les crimes de
barbie sont énumérées ces complicités
bolivienne et néo nazis révélée sans
complaisance le bourreau de lyon titre
le bilan de son attaque
une façon d'exprimer à la fois distant
et malaise envers barbie au niveau des
autorités politiques et malgré le fait
que l'extradition de klaus barbie avait
été demandée par l'allemagne fédérale
auprès de la bolivie
on peut parler ici d'un certain
soulagement en effet on considère ici
que si barbie avait été extradé en
allemagne fédérale
il aurait bénéficié comme tout un chacun
des libéralités d'une justice allemande
qui on ne répétera pas assez depuis 1949
par exemple ne connaît plus la peine de
mort le fait que ce jugement n'aurait
pas forcément été acceptée à l'étranger
notamment en france ont été une occasion
de relance d'un certain nombre de
tensions et d'animosité de ressentiment
de part et d'autre du rhin et cela les
autorités allemandes n'en voulait pas en
outre 40 ans après un crime tout
jugement reste une mission très
difficile pour n'importe quel tribunal
je crois que dans cette affaire on a
donc préféré laisser cette mission
un tribunal français il y allait de la
crédibilité et de la vérité de ce
jugement
et cette priorité un tribunal français a
été laissé
d'après des informations très précises
après une concertation très étroite au
plus haut niveau entre paris et bonn
alain weill est à peine besoin de vous
rappeler qui vous êtes et ce que vous
représentez en france vous avez été
déportée quand vous étiez enfant et
pourtant vous n'avez jamais cessé de
prêcher la modération dès qu'il s'est
agi en france d'exhumer un passé qui au
fond au fond de la conscience collective
des français n'est pas toujours et
encore bien assumer alors pour vous
barbie prisonniers en france jugés en
france
est ce que c'est une bonne chose oui je
voudrais d'abord vous dire j'avais
beaucoup hésité à faire ce soir
depuis hier on m'a demandé dans beaucoup
de citations journalistes m'ont demandé
de donner mon sentiment sur cette
expulsion
et puis ce qui m'a décidé c'est lorsque
vous m'avez parlé de ce climat
passionnel lorsque j'ai lu que peut-être
ça donnerait lieu à des règlements de
compte que l'on a les exhume mais des
vielle histoire franco-française et
alors je dois dire que ça m'inquiète
autant comme tout le monde peut être
plus que beaucoup je pense que c'est une
expulsion était souhaitable et qu'il
faut qu'il y ait un procès maintenant
exemplaire parce qu'il faut connaître
l'histoire et d'ailleurs on a beaucoup
parlé en disant c'est grâce au nouveau
régime en bolivie que barbie a été
expulsé que le problème est réglé en ce
sens me réjouis à cause de ça je crois
qu'il faut aussi se réjouir du
changement de régime parce que beaucoup
de boliviens sont sortis de prison aussi
grâce à ce changement de régime il faut
pas l'oublier
et il ne faut pas faire tourner
l'histoire autour d'un seul événement il
faut aussi penser au présent nous
n'oublions peut-être trop en pensant au
passé à ce qui s'est passé il ya 40 ans
mais le process barre mais le progrès
vision de règles y aurait alors un
chapitre que les jeux doivent y est oui
mais je crois qu'il faut l'écrire plus
dans une perspective historique de
justice au sens traditionnel du mot
parce que la justice au sens
traditionnel du mot elle n'a pas
tellement de place dans cette affaire
puisque des gens normalement les crimes
sont prêts sont prescrits et qu'il a
fallu des faits exceptionnels des crimes
contre l'humanité pour qu' il n'y ait
pas prescription il faut donc rester
dans ce caractère tout à fait
exceptionnel et je pense que si on a pas
prescrit les crimes contre l'humanité
c'est beaucoup plus dans un souci de
d'histoire on ne pas que les événements
recommence que dans le souci de
vengeance par rapport à un homme et donc
je crois que c'est vraiment à ce niveau
qu'il faut situer ce procès sans oublier
que comme vous venez de le rappeler il
ya eu depuis les procédures imbert très
peu de procès des ss aussillon de chef
de la gestapo et en europe
une des responsabilités aussi lourd et
que donc ça ne sera pas seulement un
procès qui concerne la france
enfin la justice française main procès
que l'on regardera depuis la république
fédérale d'allemagne depuis tous les
pays qui ont été occupés israël que en
israël on a fait un procès exemplaire
que le rap le procès du chien a été mené
dans des conditions aussi yeux mais vous
gagnez au fond et en florence les
passions se greffent jeu rien que je
ressens que ce qui serait un terrible
c'est d'en faire une affaire française
avec l'occasion de rechercher des des
histoires qui elles sont normalement
prescrites et de remuer des événements
qui ne s'intègre pas dans cette affaire
là où qui s'y intègre bien sûr mais de
façon tout à fait tout à fait timex même
pour des gens qui ont souffert dans leur
chair et vous en êtes
oui vous savez la prescription elle
couvre parfois les crimes abominables
des crimes d'enfants des crimes mais ce
sont des crimes individuels mais pour
les gens pour les parents qui en ont
souffert
c'est aussi grave ils ont souffert
autant même si ce sont des crimes de
droit commun que pour cette affaire là
donc je crois qu'elle doit si elle a
quelque chose d'exemplaire elle est
exceptionnel parce qu'elle s'alternent
dans un phénomène idéologique et je
crois que c'est ça qu'il faut faire
ressortir au cours du procès parce que
c'est ce qu'on a voulu c'est que ce
n'est pas tellement longue qu'on a voulu
mettre en cause bien sûr mais c'est
surtout l'idéologie idéologie d'ailleurs
dont ils se réclamaient encore récemment
en bolivie il était resté un nazi je
pense que c'est ça qu'ils font il faut
faire le procès est beaucoup plus que de
l'homme lui-même qui de toute façon sera
condamné à une peine qui ne peut
absolument pas être proportionnelle au
fait c'est elle qui aurait intérêt en
france aujourd'hui à exploiter ce
français autrement
est ce que j'écris vigile doit tenir une
expression émotionnelle
c'est pas une question d'exploitation
les choses peuvent venir d'elle-même
il peut y avoir aussi des gens qui
veulent exploiter mais je crois que
quelquefois si le déroulement d une
instruction peut donner lieu sans qu'on
le veille même à ce genre à ce genre de
dérapages et je pense que ça au trait à
ce procès son sens et un sens historique
sa dignité
je ne sais même pas une époque qu'on
juge parce qu' il peut y avoir eu
d'autres époques et mon dieu à notre
époque il s'est passé dans certains pays
des choses qui ne sont pas comparables
peut-être mais qui tout de même ce qui
s'est passé au cambodge est aussi très
grave
ce qu'on veut c'est une idéologie est ce
que cette idéologie
ce à quoi cette idéologie a conduit je
crois que c'est ça qui est important
c'est ça qui est important pour les
jeunes et pour pour que dans l'avenir il
saigne puisse pas se reproduire
le dossier
by avec tout d'abord cette incidence sur
le travail des juges d'instruction de
lyon ils ont protesté aujourd'hui contre
le surcroît de travail qui leur est
imposé par la récente suppression du
tribunal permanent des forces armées
c'est ainsi que le juge christian riss
qui doit conduire le dossier barbie a
par ailleurs sur son bureau 112 dossiers
de cet ancien tribunal qui s'ajoutent
aux 120 qui l'avait déjà à instruire et
il n'y a que dix juge d'instruction à
lyon quand on fait savoir maintenant si
le procès barbie doit être ou non
télévisé il semble que l'on ne se dirige
pas vers une exception pour barbie pour
le tortionnaire de lyon mais dès ce
matin une commission a eu une première
réunion pour examiner le principe d'une
intrusion de la télévision dans les
prétoires et le garde des sceaux robert
badinter a donné son point de vue à
michel perron ce n'est pas une
commission destinée à préparer une
décision concernant le procès barbie
c'est inadmissible qu'on se mette à
légiférer ou à prendre des décisions
réglementaires a proposé un procès est
en particulier c'est un problème
beaucoup plus vaste et la sphère barbie
c'est une affaire parmi d'autres s'y lie
à une modification de la loi
elle vaudra pour le procès barbie mais
il faudra aussi bien pour toutes les
autres affaires vous voyez c'est un
problème général
j'ai toujours aussi été sensible au fait
que historiquement nous n'avons pas les
éléments que nous aurions pu conserver
quel dommage que l'on n'ait pas la voix
de léon blum au procès pétain
quel dommage qu'on n'entende pas laval
au début de son procès se défendant lui
même
quel dommage qu'on n'ait pas conservé
l'enregistrement et du collège argoud
moment du procès les barricades
enfin les archives judiciaires sont
vides parce que l'on ne sait pas assez
soucié de voir comment l'on pouvait
réussir à conserver des documents
sonores ou visuelles suffisant et bill
est maintenant très 08 le moment venu de
notre grand dossier consacré à
l'histoire de klaus barbie incarcéré
avion depuis maintenant cinq semaines
dernier fait qui le concerne une
intervention chirurgicale pour une
hernie
le détenu se porte mieux maintenant il
est revenu à la prison saint joseph au
delà des faits l'histoire d'un homme qui
est aussi notre histoire
[Musique]
la base 25 janvier 83 l'homme d'affaires
bolivien klaus altmann est incarcéré
motif une escroquerie de 10000 dollars
commise il y a huit ans envers la
compagnie minières boliviennes
cet homme de 70 ans n'est pas un détenu
comme les autres c'est un des principaux
criminels nazis encore vivant
klaus barbie un homme dont le nom est
associé à la machine de guerre éclaire
yens sa carrière débute en 1935 barbie à
22 ans il s'enrôle dans les ss deux ans
plus tard il s'inscrit au parti nazi
puis la guerre éclate elle lui permet de
franchir rapidement les échelons du
système heatley via mes 40
il est nommé à la section des affaires
juives aux pays bas la haye depuis
amsterdam novembre 42
il prend la tête de la gestapo lyonnaise
et entreprend immédiatement la chasse
aux résistants
[Musique]
six mois après ils arrêtent jean moulin
ici dans les caves de l'école de santé
militaire les locaux de la gestapo
lyonnaise plus de 14 mille hommes femmes
et enfants passèrent entre ses mains il
est responsable de la mort de plus de
4000 personnes de la déportation de 7500
juifs ou de 45 la guerre se termine
certains chefs nazis seront jugés à
nurenberg d'autres sentiront beaucoup
mieux c'est le cas de barbie interne et
par les américains en 46 il reprend du
service chez eux et mais rapidement ses
compétences à la disposition de leurs
services secrets en 48
monsieur dabrin galce travailler pour le
sinaï si la cia de l'époque
augsbourg barbie était sous ses ordres
pendant six mois j -b qu'une presqu'avec
l'eau y est pour obtenir quel genre de
renseignements n'importe quel john doran
c'est marie labbé hills a présenté à une
supérieure à ma comme un agent allemands
pendant la guerre et il se vantait
d'être le meilleur agent de
l'intelligence la dre hamon il faut
attendre 1950 pour que les américains
vous connaissent enfin que l'ancien
responsable de la police allemande se
trouve bien sous leur contrôle
il bénéficie encore de la protection
américaine jusqu'en 51 rapport démarche
intervention diplomatique
les demandes françaises heurte à une fin
de non recevoir les américains refusent
de livrer barbe mais d'un mandat d'arrêt
est lancé contre lui
barbie devient compromettant mars 51
grâce à un document fourni par les
autorités américaines il obtient un
titre de voyage de la croix rouge
il quitte alors l'europe pour se
réfugier comme beaucoup d'anciens nazis
en amérique du sud
on n'entendra plus parler de lui pendant
20 ans
installé en bolivie sous le nom de klaus
altmann naturalisé en 57 barbie devient
homme d'affaires à la base
officiellement du moins en fait il n'a
pas vraiment abandonné son ancien métier
pendant 30 ans les régimes militaires
boliviens vont utiliser les talents de
cet expert en matière de répression et
de torture trafic d'armes trafic de
cocaïne organisation de groupes
paramilitaires
il bénéficie de la protection directe
des milieux dirigeants à deux reprises
en 52 et en 54 daf on se condamne à mort
par contumace pour crimes de guerre 1971
bête klarsfeld retrouve sa trace
la france demande alors son extradition
refus de la cour suprême bolivienne en
74 barbie peut continuer à s'afficher en
toute impunité
rien ni personne semble-t-il ne peut
l'atteindre le 20 juillet 1982
l'honorable klaus altmann parade encore
au palais de la présidence à la base en
général vient d'en remplacer un autre
apparemment rien n'a changé en fait les
militaires sont à bout de souffle
incapable de résoudre les problèmes
économiques qui s'accumulent
ils n'ont plus qu'une idée rendre le
pouvoir aux civils
entre-temps en france une information
judiciaire a été ouverte à lyon en
février 1982 elle conduira le juge
christian riss a délivré un mandat
d'arrêt le 3 novembre suivant
à peine un mois plus tôt le 10 octobre
en bolivie herman si les oiseaux leader
d'une coalition de gauche est devenu
président de la république activé par
maître serge klarsfeld et par régis
debray des tractations s'engage alors
entre la france et la bolivie
le nouveau régime de la base veut faire
un geste symbolique marquant bien sa
rupture avec les dictatures qui l'ont
précédé il a donc décidé de livrer klaus
altmann à la france le 25 janvier enfin
le criminel nazi est arrêté pour une
banale affaire de carambouille étant
donné ses nombreux trafics
il n'y avait que l'embarras du choix
dans sa prison klaus altmann barbie ne
s'inquiète pas encore la colonie
allemande de bolivie se mobilisent pour
réveiller rapidement la caution de dix
mille dollars exigée pour sa libération
malheureusement pour klaus altmann
entre temps les tractations entre la
france et la bolivie ont abouti altman
ne sera pas extradé il n'y a pas de
convention entre les deux pays
mais on a trouvé une autre solution le 4
février
alors même que les 10000 dollars de la
caution viennent d'être versée le
ministre de l'intérieur mario rorqual
signe l'arrêté d'expulsion de ce citoyen
je cite étrangers sans documents
d'identité
une expulsion quelque peu orienté
puisque klaus altmann revenus enfin
officiellement klaus barbie se retrouve
dans un hercules de l'armée bolivienne
direction la guyane française là il est
pris en charge par des policiers
français est embarqué dans un dc 8
c'est alors seulement qui la prend sa
véritable destination la france et non
l'allemagne fédérale comme il l'espérait
il sait maintenant qu'il ne sera plus
jamais un homme libre à 20 heures le 5
février 83 l'avion a atterri à la base
militaire d'orange et klaus barbie est
immédiatement transféré à lyon par
hélicoptère 22h30
d'importantes forces de police entoure
la prison militaire de montluc
plusieurs fourgons s'engouffre dans la
cour intérieure le portail se referme
sur le chef de la gestapo lyonnaise à
l'endroit même où quarante ans plus tôt
il entasse et félicie
dès le lendemain le retour de barbie
fait la une des journaux
les événements des noms des dates
réapparaissent que l'on avait un peu
oublié que surgissent alors les grandes
heures de la résistance mais aussi les
mensonges et les trahisons d'une époque
troublée
le débat est aussitôt ouvert faut-il ou
non sortir les dossiers pour certains le
procès barbie peut permettre de mieux
comprendre cet épisode de notre histoire
d'autres craignent qu'il n'y aura ni mh
des querelles enfouis et inutile qui
seraient intéressés d'en faire une
affaire française avec l'occasion de
rechercher des des histoires qui elles
sont normalement prescrites et de remuer
des événements qui ne s'intègre pas dans
cette affaire là où qu'ils s'intègrent
bien sûr mais de façon tout à fait tout
à fait unique ce soir ne se limitent pas
au grands problèmes du nazisme que nous
avons notre histoire nationale et qu'il
n'y a aucune raison pour que ce procès
si c'est possible ne contribue pas à
mieux éclairer les français sur leur
histoire nationale
ça fait un premier point à votre avis
monsieur guéant est ce que cela sera
inévitable ou bien est-ce que c'est même
souhaitable
ce serait ne donner à l'événement que la
moitié de sa signification si on
s'interdisait d'évoquer à l'instruction
et au procès les problèmes tous les
problèmes qui se réfère aux activités de
barbie chef de la gestapo de lyon de 42
à 44
certains le craignent d'autres le
souhaitent et la plupart des français se
posent la question
au lendemain de la capture de klaus
barbie va-t-on enfin lavé en public le
linge sale des années noires et surtout
va-t-on connaître enfin toute la vérité
sur la grande affaire encore en partie
mystérieuse l'arrestation par barbie à
caluire dans la banlieue lyonnaise
le 21 juin 1943 de jean moulin héros
légendaire de la résistance française
jean moulin était un prêt chez il avait
été chef de cabinet de pierre cot il
avait eu une attitude exemplaire au
moment de la guerre d'espagne
tout cela était difficilement admis et
dans la résistance en tant que
fédérateur avait
obliger un certain nombre de dirigeants
aussi bien d'ailleurs en france qu'à
londres admettre autour de la table du
conseil national de la résistance les
représentants des partis politiques
oui c'était beaucoup plus que le symbole
de la résistance riou jean moulin
étaient représentatifs de la république
et du front populaire
homme de gauche grand commis de l'état
homme de confiance du général de gaulle
jean moulin a été fait pour cette
mission à laquelle il s'est attelé
depuis 18 mois
rassembler les grands courants de la
résistance y compris les communistes
sous la bannière du conseil national de
la résistance qu'il préside à la
direction de l'armée secrète placée
directement sous son autorité les
représentants de libération et de
francs-tireurs le soutiennent mais les
amis d'henri freiner le fondateur de
combat conteste ces orientations le 9
juin à paris le chef d'état major de
l'armée secrète le général delestraint
est tombé aux mains de la gestapo
les arrestations se multiplient il est
urgent de provoquer une réunion au
sommet de l'organisation
elle est fixée au 21 juin à 14 heures
chez le docteur dugoujon place
castellane à caluire sept hommes sont
convoqués en dehors de jean moulin le
colonel la case patriotes père
tranquille
nouveau venu à l'état-major de la s
bruno lara jeune combattant venu de
londres avec jean moulin raymond aubrac
chefs des groupes paramilitaires du
mouvement libération proche de jean
moulin
andré la sagne un professeur lyonnais
organisateurs de la réunion paris aubry
porte parole d'henri freiné à
l'état-major de la s est souvent en
désaccord avec jean moulin le colonel
schwarz feld fondateur de france d'abord
rallié à la s et enfin claude bou chine
et ses râles venu de londres quelques
jours plus tôt pour secondes et jean
moulin et qui aura la chance de manquer
le rendez vous c'est vrai je n'étais pas
au rendez vous parce que j'étais arrivé
depuis peu a lyon je connaissais très
mal la topographie de la ville et je me
suis trompé deux funiculaires cette
réunion que vous avez manqué sa non
c'était difficile
évidemment le problème pour moulin à
partir du moment où il apprend qu'à
paris delestraint vient d'être arrêté
son organisation militaire et décapité
il n'a plus le dos les styles a plus
personne pour diriger et coordonner
cette action militaire il fallait donc
colmater la brèche et trouver quelqu'un
qui assure un intérim est l'objet de
cette réunion qui regroupait les
principaux responsables des mouvements
de résistance dans le domaine militaire
était de préparer les voies la
désignation d'un intérimaire trois
hommes connaissent le lieu de rendez
vous jean moulin qui doit amener avec
lui aubrac et schwarz feld lara qui doit
prévenir la case et la sagne chargé de
réceptionner aubry au terminus du
funiculaire de la croix paquet en fait à
la grande surprise de la sagne aubry
n'arrive pas seul avec lui
rené hardy responsable des sabotages sur
le réseau de chemin de fer lui aussi
proche d'henri freiner aubry l'a amené
avec lui de son propre chef pour l'aider
à tenir tête à jean-moulin aubry qui a
rencontré jean moulin le matin même sans
le prévenir de cette initiative aubry
qui accumule les imprudences la veille
en effet à l'occasion d'un rendez vous
avec le même rené hardy au pont morand
il a remarqué la présence suspecte d'un
inconnu se dissimulant derrière son
journal est assis sur un banc aux côtés
de hardy c'est tom hardy le connais bien
c'est klaus barbie comme il le
reconnaîtra lui-même au cours de son
second procès en 1950 alors qu'il avait
menti au cours du premier en 47 hardy a
été arrêté quelques jours plus tôt par
la gestapo
après une dizaine d'heures
d'interrogatoire barbie a obtenu de lui
une promesse de collaboration et la
libérer presque tout de suite
hardy a repris ses activités dans la
résistance sans prévenir ses camarades
si vous aviez su à l'époque que rené
hardy
avait été arrêté quelques jours plus tôt
par barbie sans en prévenir ses
camarades et ses chefs
comment auriez-vous réagi la règle
draconienne atroce cruel mais impossible
à écarter se tait d'abattre ce top 21
juin 14h 45 environ les derniers arrivés
au rendez-vous de caluire moulin aubrac
et schwarz feld viennent à peine d'être
introduit dans la salle d'attenté du
docteur dugoujon les cinq autres
attendent dans la salle du premier étage
depuis trois quarts d'heure tout à coup
les tractions de la gestapo s'arrête
devant la villa à la tête du commando
klaus barbie police allemande
vous avez une réunion chez nous je leur
ai dit non mais ils m'ont pas cru c'est
dommage
sim avait cru qu elle changé le cours de
l'histoire
alors sincèrement bruits sont entrés
dans le petit salon et par la porte
fenêtre vous verrez puis au premier
étage alors lâché tel remue-ménage des
décrets du bruit de 2,2 de shell
les hurlements de cheyrou voilà quand
ils sont sortis un seul homme n'avait
pas de menottes et en basse h et mardi
se suit autre chose alors hardy coupable
ou non coupable
par deux fois en 1947 puis en 1950 il
sera acquitté au bénéfice du doute
il s'agit donc de chose jugée mais tout
de même quelle facilité à échapper aux
griffes de la police la plus féroce qui
soit et puis il y à la troublante
question des menottes à caluire tout le
monde est brutalement menotté les mains
derrière le dos tout le monde sauf hardy
expliquez vous n'avez pas de menace
tu aimes tu es passé ça arrive ça ce
sont des choses qui arrivent et vous
avez réussi à vous enfuir de quelle
façon tout simplement au moment de
monter dans la voiture
claquant la porte hier a été
déséquilibré il à la gerbe du cabriolet
rouge alors il ya quelqu'un qui
descendait entend des cris dans
l'escalier plus de coups de feu sur la
place mais pas su ce qui s'était passé
je n'ai pas vu au tout coeur alors s'il
a redit qu'il s'est échappé dans des
conditions serait trop long de raconter
sable on a dit que vous étiez échapper
un peu facilement carrure ne faisait pas
une valeur la peau au moment de la
fouille pourtant minutieuse toujours
aussi chanceux hardy a réussi selon ses
propres dires à dissimuler son arme en
le soupçonnera de s'être blessé lui même
plus étonnant encore arrêté est tombé à
nouveau dans les mains de klaus barbie
quelques jours plus tard il s'échappera
une seconde fois ses compagnons au moins
de chance déjà brutalement malmené par
barbie chez le docteur dugoujon à coups
de pieds de table et sont embarqués à
l'école de santé militaire le siège de
la gestapo
la plupart d'entre eux seront
horriblement torturé mais c'est bien sûr
contre jean moulin que barbie
s'acharnera le plus sauvage ou ment sans
jamais parvenir à lui arracher la
moindre confidence j'ai vu pour la
dernière fois de ma vie
jean moulin descendre l'escalier il
était vivant mais il avait de tout de
toute certitude été battus très dur non
et il avait le visage en sont ils
avaient la tête couvert de
ville un pansement il ne marchait pas il
était porté sous les bras par deux
policiers allemands et comme il se
dirigeait encore vers un interrogatoire
j'ai eu le sentiment que vraiment je le
voyais pour la dernière fois
jean moulin est il tombé à cause des
imprudences de certains de ses camarades
ou at il été délibérément trail même
pour ses compagnons les plus proches il
est bien difficile d'affirmer autre
chose qu une intime conviction
la gestapo n'est pas venu tout seul au
rendez vous ça c'est une certitude
et elle n'est pas venue avec dix
voitures 40 personnes et des moyens
considérables
ça ne peut pas être le hasard il ya donc
certainement une délation à l'origine
n'ai jamais pu tirer ça au clair par la
suite jamais il subsiste un mystère et
je crois que ce mystère ne sera
peut-être jamais levé sûrement pas en
tout cas par barbie qui est le dernier à
pouvoir témoigner sur cette affaire
étant donné qu'il ne défendra jamais que
sa cause personnelle et tout son intérêt
il agira pour sa défense et ne pas pour
projeter la lumière ou la vérité
ceux qui espéraient que le procès barbie
permettrait enfin de faire la lumière
sur toutes ces questions demeurées sans
réponses devront en prendre leur parti
klaus barbie ne sera jugé que pour ses
crimes contre les populations civiles
le dossier jean moulin est
définitivement clos une liste de huit
chefs d'inculpation a déjà été établi en
bonne place les événements qui se sont
produits ici à izieu un petit village de
l'ain le 6 avril 1944 les hommes de
barbie embarqués dans des camions 55
juifs réfugiés dans le village dans 52
enfants
destination les camps de la mort il
avait chargé sa part à kiel comme dans
les salles de pommes de terre il avec l
âge des enfants 17 août 1944 70 juifs de
tous âges sont amenés sur le terrain
d'aviation de bron pendant plusieurs
heures
ils creusent des fausses au soir ils
sont tous fusillés sur ordre de barbie
20 août 1944 saint-genis-laval près de
lyon des juifs des syndicalistes des
résistants des otages sont amenés ici en
camion ils sont exécutés par vagues
successives dans un fort désaffecté puis
le bâtiment est dynamitée monsieur paul
roux avait 14 ans à l'époque il faut
partir on a remonté on est monté avec
d'autres gens et ça on l'a lu éparpillés
quoi les débris du mains nues par les
explosions
combien était-il 90 100 120 on ne sait
pas exactement arrestations massives
torture déportation fusillade
la liste est monotone elle n'est pas
encore définitive
d'autres crimes contre l'humanité commis
ici à la prison du fort montluc
ou en d'autres lieux pourront s'y
ajouter au cours de l'instruction crimes
de guerre crimes contre l'humanité
qu'importe résistants juifs aux otages
ont partagé les mêmes souffrances les
mêmes tortures
quarante ans après ils vont revivre
ensemble dans le souvenir des français
d'aujourd'hui c'est une chose qui ne
qu'il faut pas oublier parce que bon
klaus barbie ya aussi souffrir d'
énormément de gens et je pense que des
gens comme ça qui ont torturé
bon ça s'est passé il ya quarante ans
c'est évident mais on doit se sentir
concerné quand même parce que c'est un
problème d'humanité un criminel de
guerre comme ça il faut il faut essayer
de de pouvoir l'obtenir supposer qu'ils
arabe fou comme commis clair qu'ils
aient envie de revenir il faudrait qu'on
montre qu'on n'est pas passif et qu'on
peut qu'on peut punir qu'on a les moyens
de finir dont quarante ans après on ne
doit pas pardonner surtout pas
[Musique]
harbi est normal ce pourrait être le
titre du rapport transmis au ministère
de la justice par deux médecins et un
psychologue qui ont examiné et
questionner le criminel de guerre dans
sa prison de lyon klaus barbie et même
d'une intelligence supérieure à la
moyenne conclut le rapport
et il est en bonne forme intellectuelle
et ne se sent absolument pas coupable à
titre personnel irons-nous des actions
qu'on lui reproche au cours de l'
enquête qu'elle mène actuellement betty
du rau a rencontré des témoins qui ont
connu rencontré klaus barbie à l'époque
où il était en france et leurs
témoignages ne concordent pas forcément
avec l'idée qui est de ne donner de lui
au travers de ce rap à l'évidence dans
ce rapport klaus barbie ici à la prison
saint joseph préfère parler de sa
famille plutôt que de la période
d'occupation à lyon où il était le chef
de la quatrième section du service de
sécurité du troisième reich
il fait part aux experts de l'admiration
ressenti pour son père instituteur
relégué dans une toute petite école a eu
l'air en rhénanie peut-être parce qu'il
était un peu trop porté sur la bouteille
en tout cas tel est le sentiment d'un
camarade de classe du petit klaus you
natale rothaine que vous voyez là
montrer par ce crayon et que nous avons
rencontrés sur les lieux mène dans la
classe capable mais le buveur autre
remarque de klaus barbie
il traite le président bolivien et
vibrante d'enfants naturel mal les
aurait-il oublié sa propre naissance le
25 octobre 1913 ici avant le mariage de
ses parents le 30 janvier 1914
mais ce réellement important et barbie
de continuer je le cite en face de la
réalité je me concentre uniquement sur
elle et fait taire tout sentiment
réaction de simone lagrange torturé à 13
ans par barbie est confronté à ces
derniers il y a quelques mois
extraits
je suis témoin dans la sphère de barbie
j'ai des raisons de tout témoin je me
regardais beaucoup
barbie est parti de rire en disant mais
non si je regarde là c'est qu'elle est
très appétissante et que ça fait sept
mois que je suis en prison je suis un
homme
le rapport précise que gosses barbie ne
ressens ni sentiment de culpabilité ni
conflits internes
alors tant pis pour les enr esman
confronté lui aussi à cause barbie qui a
fait déporter toute sa famille
quant à elle à revenir la ramener en
france je ne comprends pas soit il n'y a
pas si longtemps
ce que je voudrais c'est que j'espère ce
que je souhaite c'est comme barbie un
cri du coeur qu'il manifeste que ceux
qui l' effet ils étaient obligés de le
faire parce qu'il y avait deux ordres
mais qu'il le regrette
dans un mois le 11 mai 1987 s'ouvrira au
palais de justice de lyon le procès de
klaus barbie
d'ici cette date nous évoquerons
régulièrement et plus complètement
possible le dossier barbie mais ce soir
je vous propose avec betty dureau et les
détails des préparatifs de ce procès
notamment l'installation matérielle en
cours dans la salle des pas perdus du
palais de justice de lyon 13 heures
lundi 11 mai 87 s'ouvre pour la première
fois en france le procès d'un criminel
nazi klaus barbie incarcéré à la prison
saint joseph de lyon depuis plus de
quatre ans entrera ici dans la salle des
pas perdus du palais de justice
c'est le seul endroit assez grands pour
recevoir après travaux les quelques 700
personnes attendues journaliste témoin
et observateurs venus du monde entier
pour ce procès de l'un des responsables
de la gestapo de lyon
des consignes strictes de sécurité
portique de filtrage à l'entrée de la
salle où l'accusé ne sera séparée du
public par une barrière de plexiglas un
système semblable à celui des aéroports
devant l'accusé son avocat jacques
vergès en face l'avocat général pierre
truche l'accusation le président andré
serdy ni présidents d'assises arbitres
et juges du procès à s'écouter deux
assesseurs gérard becker et andré
pichery neuf jurés femmes et hommes qui
ressort sur une liste d'habitants des
communes du rhône
à la barre se succéderont 45 avocat
parmi eux de très grands noms du barreau
français pour représenter les quelques
cent une partie civile trois caméras
filmeront l'intégralité des débats pour
les archives de france diffusion au plus
tôt en 2007 selon la loi trois jours
avant l'ouverture du procès de klaus
barbie devant la cour d'assises de lyon
parmi les nombreuses analyses publiées
nous a semblé intéressant ce soir avec
betty dureau et françois granier
d'évoquer la personnalité de barbie
comment est il devenu un petit chef nazi
betty du rau a fait appel notamment un
homme résistants allemands qui fûtes
interprète au procès de nuremberg
un vrai 1933 klaus barbie 20 ans
s'inscrit au générique aériennes comme
la plupart de ses jeunes compatriotes
cette adhésion marque pour lui le début
de son activité politique
ss en septembre 1935 fausses barbes y
adhère au parti nazi en 37 sous le
numéro 4 millions 583 milles 0,85
né dans une famille catholique et
villageoises il passe une enfance de
petit allemands ordinaires sous la
férule d'un père instituteur il admire
pour sa conduite pendant la guerre de 14
mai le craint pour sa rudesse et ses
violences de buveurs l'amour de ce père
en 33 empêche qu aux barbies
d'entreprendre des études supérieures et
le pousse à chercher notre voie de
promotion sociale
le national socialisme sera sa chance
dirrell eu la chance dû rater parce que
ça c'était caractéristique le salut de
tous ces gens là on les a vus loi après
l'autre au banc des accusés à denis
robert c'était des petites gens avec des
petits ce sentiment dmd fidélité avec
beaucoup de sentimentalité sont de
véritables sentiments une bande de
petits des gens sont véritables
carrières des gens de caractère dont
envergure moins que le moyenne et vous
est signée parfaitement barbie à ces
gens là
voilà la conclusion je pense on
connaîtra les détails que barbie était
tout à fait approprié dès l'origine dès
le début de sa carrière à ce genre de
d'action et de crimes auxquels jour j
moins deux pour l'ouverture du procès
barbie 800 journalistes sont attendus
pour ce procès historique qui est aussi
un procès pour l'histoire le procédé
fait sera retransmis par les télévisions
mais il fera aussi enregistré pour
l'histoire par la télévision
paul lefèvre premier procès jamais
filmés en france dans son intégralité et
pour l'histoire
cinq caméras de fr3 en permanence une
régie complète un film réalisé sous la
surveillance d'un magistrat celui ci
doit faire respecter les équilibres des
prises de vue un travail considérable
le président des assises pourra à chaque
instant arrêtez l'enregistrement
si un témoin par exemple refuse d'être
filmé chaque jour les cassettes seront
mis sous scellés par le président des
assises qui les vérifiera et qu'il les
confiera aux archives de france
ce film destiné à l'histoire ne pourra
être utilisé que
en vingt ans aucune répétition n'étant
possible
il s'agira d'un véritable direct tout
est prêt pour cette expérience dont on
saura vite si elle est bénéfique pour la
justice le procès peut commencer
[Musique]
madame monsieur bonjour regardez cette
image c'est finalement celle de la
démocratie celle de la justice quarante
trois ans après son départ dans le
dernier train le 30 août 1940 classe
klaus barbie redevient l'homme que tous
les données regarde
l'audience va commencer dans quelques
instants
elle a pris évidemment un peu de retard
comme toutes les manifestations de ce
poids et de cette importance
les photographes et les cameramen
agissent encore pour filmer les parties
civiles et l'arrivée de maître vergès le
défenseur de klaus barbie
il y a toute la presse mondiale réunis
dans cette salle pour juger un dossier
qui dépasse de loin le cadre générale
ordinaire de ce qui se jugent dans la
cour d'assises de lyon klaus barbie est
arrivé il ya quelques instants dans le
palais de justice de lyon son convoi
fortement escorté à traverser la ville
par un itinéraire qui a été choisi au
dernier moment
il est rentré dans le dépôt et il a été
aussitôt emmené dans la cellule de repos
que vous avons montré l'autre jour où
son avocat maître vergès c'est venu le
voir ainsi que le médecin du samu qui
doit tout au long du procès surveiller
l'état santé de l'accusé
dans quelques instants le président des
assises andré serghini doit entrer par
cette porte que vous voyez au fond de
l'image
il sera accompagné de deux assesseurs
les conseillers les cours d'appel beke
et pichery tu le président sadi n'y va
être accompagnée également de deux
magistrats suppléant supplémentaires qui
vont suivre les débats avec lui et qui
pourront remplacer les magistrats
titulaire si l'un d'eux à un malaise ou
un empêchement quelconque tout au long
de ce procès la salle des pas perdus du
palais de lyon a été aménagé pour qu'on
tire environ 7 à 800 personnes
je crois qu'il y en a beaucoup plus
maintenant déjà et cette salle a une
histoire finalement parce que depuis sa
construction le palais de lyon est
beaucoup trop petit il a été construit
en 1842 par lui baltard et dès la fin de
sa construction
on est obligés d'ajouter deux bâtiments
et de niveaux qui ont été achetés en
on doit depuis longtemps à lyon
construire une cité judiciaire
mais on l'attend encore voici maintenant
la sonnerie qui annonce l'arrivée de la
cour voici le président andré serghini
[Musique]
le président ressorti à 58 ans le
président de la cour d'assises du rhône
depuis trois ans
et rentrer avec lui l'avocat général
pierre truche 58 ans au coeur général de
lyon également depuis trois ans qui sera
assisté par le substitut général
jean-olivier viout qui seront ces deux
derniers magistrats étant l'accusation
le voici le voka général pierre truche
voici jean les vieilles view l'audience
est ouverte
je demande aux services d'ordre
d'introduire l'accusé simulait
voici posséder de ses gardes
l'os bas
il faisait régner la terreur aujourd'hui
la justice
lui demander que vous pourriez vous
asseoir nous sommes accusés six celle du
code pénal maintenir celle qui doit
messieurs gladys qui vit dans les villes
et la défense les avocats de la partie
des participants
l'image ça peut jouer réellement dans
quelques instants de cette lotion à ses
victimes
admission et de parler
les retraites préfère le brouillard
oxydatif les gens sont gentils je ne
suis pas la peine d'y laisser des
nations les connais paul villach teckel
théoriquement leur maître les promoteurs
celle d'être présent mettre l'humain
elysées nous l'envient parle très bien
le français mais comme eux mais il veut
sans doute heath en unissant la division
se soumettre les chirac avait peur le
président s'est dit ni fait actuellement
l'appel des parties civiles monsieur
portes voici l'ensemble des abonnés ils
t'avaient alan brenner reconnaître les
climats gemert drapeau bohème et trial
uci
vous avez madame choix c'est minable et
latin voilà vous avez monsieur el raï
l'algérien m celle qui revient bien
entendu qui va être partie civile l'un
des avocats les plus importants
puisqu'il a mené à une masse de
documents à la cuisse à terme l'outil
garde fanni mais nos héros
roland dumas exa également mettre au
rhino guerre prison la ligue des droits
de l'homme
mahdia j'irai d'ailleurs ou non que
cette association monsieur
madame klaus barbie que vous voyez à
parer à une nouvelle génération comme le
symbole du nazisme
c'est sans doute un fois que trazom pour
un homme de 74 ans jugé pour des ânes
tout connu alors qu'il n'avait que 27
ans il était au moment de sa présence le
symbole de la puissance et de
l'arbitraire protéger encouragé par ces
chefs ont été d'ailleurs jugé et gracié
qui sont aujourd'hui en liberté
aujourd'hui finalement klaus barbie est
seul il faut le reconnaître il portait
le numéro 2 139 dans la liste des
criminels de guerre
en réalité il ne reste plus en liberté
qu'un seul lunel nazis classé parmi les
premiers à louise bruner on sait où il
vit à damas en syrie
il semble y être en sécurité
klaus barbie apparaît en bonne santé ces
médecins qui l'ont examiné récemment
l'ont confirmé au président les assises
il s'intéresse visiblement à la lys à
l'énoncé de la liste des parties civiles
vous voyez peut-être l'un l'une des
interprètes lui annoncer et lui désigné
mais c'est ce avocat aj des avocats des
associations qui sont portées syli
partie civile contre lui je m'entendais
très bien peu près seul vol il faut
préciser je crois que si nous voyons en
ce moment que la hausse parmi ces parce
qu'il a accepté d'être filmée par les
télévisions il avait le droit de refuser
absolument il avait le droit de refuser
il l'a fait d'ailleurs mais
l'interprétation juridique de la loi a
permis au président de passer outre pour
ce qui concerne l'enregistrement
historique aussi d'anciennes
l'enregistrement d'actualité de leur
vision leur vie finalement se décider à
accepter alors qu'au départ semble-t-il
il était plutôt opposés et pas nous
avons le droit de filmer comme on le
voit en ce moment les premières minutes
de ce procès mais c'est tout n'est ce
pas oui alors nous allons dans quelques
instants à la fin de l'énoncé des
parties civiles arrêter la transmission
or ce que nous allons aborder l'un des
moments les plus sucrés en quelque sorte
de huis clos du procès c'est à dire la
désignation des jurés ne jurer qu'ils
avaient que les trois magistrats je
romps constitueront la cour d'assises
le présidentialisme va très certainement
prendre cinq ou six jurés
supplémentaires pour rallier là aussi un
éventuel empêchement d'un juré alors six
jurés dont nous avons connaissance de la
liste originale sont des lyonnais bien
entendu moyenne d'âge 35 40 ans de deux
niveaux ce jeu professionnel moyens
surtout ce qui est important ce qui sont
très jeunes c'est une génération
finalement dit art n'a pas connu barbie
il a aidé mon helaba connu barbie comme
le juge d'instruction christian riss
d'ailleurs qui au moment où il a reçu le
dossier n'avait que 37 ans les jurés
seront désignés et ensuite on passera à
l'appel des témoins et des moins pour
certains en égalant presque tous
d'ailleurs et qui vont après avoir
assuré de leur présence est reconduit
dre celle des témoins ne pourront en
sortir qu au moment où le président
savini lors de contrats de repli et à
votre avis pour combien de temps va
prendre la lecture par le greffier de
l'acte d'accusation quatre ou cinq
heures probablement vous savez que la
petite association ce sont ces la vie de
barbie c'est ce sont les faits qui lui
sont reprochés
et c'est également la liste des charges
et pas sur lui
vous savez que klaus barbie est accusé
de plusieurs crimes contre l'humanité
qui peuvent se résumer en cinq grandes
lignes d'abord la rafle la déportation
des 50 enfants 10,2 au xixe yeux c'était
d'en haut le 6 avril 44
et puis la liquidation aussi le 9
février 43 du comité de l'union générale
des israélites de france est ce qu'on
appelle la rafle de la rue
sainte-catherine
ensuite le dernier train du conte ou 44
650 personnes au moins 40 a perdu la
liste évidemment n'a pas été retrouvée
de manière définitive le train du 11 44
tirs emmener tous ces gens dans les
camps de concentration alors que barbie
à ce mois-là pouvait très bien les
laisser comme d'autres allemands l'ont
fait dans d'autres régions de france
alain époque les alliés arrivé c'était
plutôt tellement nécessaire d'envoyer
les gens en concentration barney a
assisté et a signé 7 sept emplois
ensuite il y a deux
crimes contre l'humanité particulier
l'un intéressant le podium marcel gompel
10 est mort à la suite en déportation
mais qu elle était auparavant torturé
par barbie rentrant ensuite la
déportation et la mort de georges le cem
de son fils elle met sa femme également
lisent le serbe a été déporté mais elle
est revenue elle est dans la salle et
son témoignage sera simplement très
lourd d'ailleurs on peut penser que et
en dehors des 4,5 pièces ou vernis sont
des documents et qu'ils pèseront lourd
sur la commission des jurés ce qui va
sûrement en importer le plus ce sera la
longue déposition de cette liste de
témoins qui viendront raconter viendront
raconter ce qui s'est passé et je pense
que ces témoignages aura un symbole
particulier parce que ces gens ont
souvent dit que leurs camarades qui
mouraient à leurs côtés dans les camps
de concentration on leur disait vivait
pour raconter et sans ces gens viennent
aujourd'hui témoigner c'est peut-être là
peu plus important de leur vie
maintenance et de témoigner de la
souffrance et de la mort de leur copain
il faut rappeler épaules que ces crimes
contre l'humanité sont imprescriptibles
à la différence bien sûr des crimes de
guerre oui les crimes de guerre sont
prescriptibles à partir comme tir des
dix ans au delà disant pardon tandis que
les crimes contre l'humanité sont
imprescriptibles en fonction de la
définition du tribunal de nuremberg du 8
août 1945
d'ailleurs c'était 7 imprescriptibilité
ce voyage ou sous la dir est a introduit
reconnu dans le droit français par une
loi du 16 septembre 64 adoptée par
l'ensemble du parlement bien entendu et
alors
la cour de cassation le juge
d'instruction avait d'abord en
appliquant le strict droit français
écarté du dossier un certain nombre de
places par ce parce qu'ils considéraient
qu'il venait de résistants de gens
arrêtés comme résistant et ensuite
déporté la suite d'appels successifs la
cour de jambes la cour de cassation la
chambre criminelle a donné le 20
décembre 85 une nouvelle définition du
crime contre l'humanité qui va
d'ailleurs être inscrit dans les textes
internationaux
on peut résumer cette subvention en
disant que son crime contre l'humanité
les actes inhumains commis au nom d'une
hégémonie idéologique pour persécuter
pour des restes des motifs raciaux et
religieux réduction en esclavage
déportation en sommes à partir de là les
unes français ont tous considéré que le
fait même d'envoyer quelqu'un en
déportation de le réduire à la mort par
la faim ou pas un travail fatigant et
est un crime contre
qualité et c'est ainsi que plusieurs
personnes qui avaient été écartés par le
juge christian riss en conformité avec
la l'ancienne définition de la loi ont
pu rentrer dans mais aussi arrondi pour
se retrouver aujourd'hui et témoigner
contre lui
est ce que vous savez quand vont
commencer les plaidoiries des avocats
car l'affrontement pas s'annonce très
rude entre maître vergès l'avocat de
barbie et puis m e klarsfeld l'un des
avocats des parties civiles bien
d'autres patricia pendant que le
président continue de la lecture des
parties civiles
je vous donne un petit peu le programme
et je répondre ainsi à votre question
après la désignation du jury aujourd'hui
au lit ensuite l'appel des témoins nous
allons commencer cet après-midi à
entendre la lecture de l'acte
d'accusation par le greffier monsieur de
sage de garage qui est un petit peu au
dessus de barbie a dû gauche et alors
la création est prévue pour environ 5 à
6 heures
[Musique]
marc et pendant puisque débat est
ensuite l'acte d'accusation que nous
aurons là le récit de la vie de barbie
mais pas les faits ensuite dans deux
jours probablement les psychiatres de
psychiatres psychologues qui ont été
examinés par vie et qui viendront nous
dire quelles sont ces structures
psychologiques et psychiques
je pense que nous commençons à étudier
l'effet cas lundi qu'au début peut-être
la fin de cette semaine au début de la
semaine prochaine
en réalité l'affrontement va commencer
au moment de l'interrogatoire sur les
faits qui commencera probablement mais
au début de la semaine prochaine et
cette drogue at war sera certainement le
signal de l'affrontement entre défense
et partie civile c'est à dire que maître
vergès vague est d'ores et déjà avoir à
réfuter ou a révélé en quelque sorte sa
stratégie de défense
ensuite le long défilé des témoins sans
doute des semaines et des semaines il y
avait un sens un témoin et des gens que
l'on ne peut pas interrompre parce qu'il
est que le je vous disais tout à l'heure
ils ont vraiment des choses à dire et je
pense que les plaidoiries ne
commenceront
au début du mois de juillet une question
comme sur les magistrats y savent bien
sûr que ce procès est historique
puisqu'il est sans doute l'un des
derniers de la guerre dont il est témoin
soit survivants comment ont-ils préparé
et bien d'abord comme je vous l ai dit
tout à l'heure le juge christian riss
qui a reçu le dossier le 12 février 82
qui est maintenant substitut pour les
sceptiques à besançon avait 35 ans à
l'époque c'est lui qui a instruit ce
dossier historique dans les conditions
très difficiles
l'accusation était donc représenté par
le parquet général de lyon monsieur
pierre truche ci a considérablement aidé
avec son substitut monsieur view dia
considérablement aider le juge crise
dans la recherche de la vérité et
surtout dans la recherche des documents
monde serge klarsfeld a beaucoup
retrouver de documents je peux vous dire
que l'essentiel des documents qui sont
actuellement dans le dossier ont été
retrouvés par serge klarsfeld qui l'a
évidemment automatiquement communiqué
vous partagez cette instruction
lorsque le juge d'instruction a eu
terminé son enquête il a clos le dossier
il l'a confié au parquet général de lyon
et la chambre d'accusation de lyon a
réexaminé pour se voir si le dossier
était complet elle a commencé la longue
procédure dont ce n'est pas le tout à
l'heure c'est à dire dès la définition
des crimes de guerre et contre
l'humanité
ça a duré de longs mois parce que le
dossier partida cour d'appel de lyon il
est remonté à la kalach criminelle de la
cour de cassation qui a confié le
supplément d'enquêté à la cour d'appel
de paris qu'on appel de paris a bouclé
on dit ficelé en terme sur les lycans
plutôt en terme de jargon juridique
cafice l'aide au ciel avant dans leur
royaume devant la cour d'assises du
rhône et pour jugement est ce que la
durée de 4 ans qui a été nécessaire pour
cette instruction depuis l'arrivée de
barbe et à la prison de lyon vous semble
un temps normal pour cette instruction
aux je pense même que c'est relativement
court lorsqu'on examine l'ensemble des
procédures criminelles en france
l'instruction de ces procès au criminel
je pense que quand un dossier pareil
d'une telle complexité qui nécessitait
des recherches un peu partout dans le
monde
je crois que ça a été relativement vite
l'association des parties klaus barbie
est actuellement voyez en train
d'observer les parties civiles sont face
à lui il est installé
il est installé dans
dans un box le box des accusés on le
voit mal meliani une sorte de vitres qui
est à l'épreuve des balles
il le protège en quelque sorte d'une
agression donc à côté de lui les deux
interprètes qui vont se relayer en
dessous son avocat maître vergès et sa
collaboratrice mme c'est un long chemin
que cet homme à parcourir avant
d'arriver il est certain que sinon la
fin de sa vie c'est probablement la fin
de son aventure et on ne sait pas très
bien quelle stratégie personnelle il y
va il aura au cours de ce procès battent
ils suivre complètement la tactique de
mètres derrière son avocat où va-t-il
révélé entre guillemets un certain
nombre de choses c'est à dire quoi
les liens qu'ils pourraient avoir eu
avec un stand de lyonnais où les
révélations qu'il pourrait faire sur des
[Musique]
mystères - venus de la collaboration
ainsi aux jouets l'entendre le président
s'est dit ni demande maintenant à la
presse de laisser sans s'écarter en
respect de la loi
car nous allons arriver comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure à la désignation
des jurés qui sont lui l'appareil de
photo l'appareil dans ce fil du temps de
l'image à cesser cet enregistrement je
vous le rappelle et le progrès de
l'histoire judiciaire française
il a lu un symbole de films qui ont été
pris par exemple au moment du procès
pétain et du procès la balle aussi
c'étaient des films qui ne voudrait pas
lente l'entière durée des procès avec
enregistrement historique dans les
camarades vont rester en mouvement et
qui vont tourner
continuellement sous la surveillance
d'un magistrat dit va tenter de
respecter
l'objectivité la mesure des images les
cassettes seront remises
tous les soirs président des assises qui
les confiera aux archers de france on
pourra les consulter ou de 20 ans et les
utiliser au bout de 30 ans des
télévisions par dizaines et une
cinquantaine de radios du monde entier
l'eurovision pile h au rendez-vous de
13h et à 13h04 pour être précis mille
cinq cent cinquante cinq jours après son
extradition de bolivie
klaus barbie s'est retrouvé dans le box
des accusés du palais de justice de lyon
pour la première fois en france les
débats d'un procès d'assises seront
entièrement filmé et enregistré par
quatre caméras installées en permanence
dans la salle d'audience tous les soirs
un magistrat récupérera les cassettes
qui seront mises joue scellés et
expédiés sous bonne escorte dans une
chambre forte des archives
départementales du rhône
les enregistrements ne pourront être
visionnées librement par le grand public
que dans cinquante ans mais ce n'est
qu'à partir de l'an 2007 que les
cassettes du procès pourront être
consultés par des historiens à titre
individuel qu'après l'accord conjoint du
garde des sceaux et du ministre de la
culture
à 11h55 ce matin les portes de la prison
saint joseph s'ouvrait le fourgon
cellulaire transportant klaus barbie se
diriger vers le palais du sis de lyon
mais un quart d'heure avant le transfert
la circulation sur les quais de saône
avait été interrompue 12h05 klaus barbie
arrive au palais de justice mais avant
l'ouverture de ce procès maître vergès
l'avocat de klaus barbie dénoncent déjà
l'aspect médiatique de ce procès il est
choqué il est indigné d'un procès qui
est préparé comme un lynchage des deux
d'exhibition dans la ville où il est
présenté comme un coupable avant tout
jugement
il est choqué et indigné de ce que dans
les écoles des professeurs non seulement
parlent de la des camps de déportation
mais le fond des termes tels que c'est
bas rhin c'est lui qui semble
responsable de cela avant qu'un tribunal
dans des juges et dix minutes après
l'arrivée de barbie une dizaine de
membres de l'association des fils et
filles des déportés juifs de france sont
arrivés auprès du stif pour remettre des
bouquets de roses multicolores
ap ap par semaine mais dès 11h30 le
public se présenter devant le palais de
justice seules les 50 premières
personnes ont été admises dans la salle
d'audience
je demande aux services d'ordre
d'introduire l'accusé simulait
13h05 klaus barbie menottes aux mains
fait son entrée dans la salle et gagne
le box des accusés le président serbie
ni de mandat klaus barbie
comprenez vous suffisamment le français
pour suivre les débats
réponse des interprètes il veut parler
en allemand messieurs et mesdames et
messieurs les avocats de la partie
civile dans la salle plus de 700
journalistes suivent ce procès
représentant 250 médias dont 25 chaînes
de télévision mais écoutez déjà les
réactions du public
je dirais personnellement j'avais les
larmes aux yeux en pensant aux 7500
juifs déportés depuis lyon alors que
l'accusé rien était extrêmement
satisfait je crois que c'est tout le
climat qui nous sépare effectivement
c'est impressionnant c'est
impressionnant
l'impression qu'une toute une équipe
toute une époque est en procès de ces
procès d'une époque il est témoin que
tout à l'heure qui a dit il n'est pas
venu là pour la vengeance et je pense
que qu'il a raison c'est pour symbole
tour
tbilissi
ne pas oublier enfin ça met mal à l'aise
quand on voit barbier avec sont donc je
plaisante un petit peu avec son
interprète et qui vont mettre là j'ai
six enfants nés à terme
mal à l'aise
vous allez revenir je suis barbie on
comptait revenir ça va l'image et le
coup de théâtre du jour klaus barbie
quittant la salle d'audience de la cour
d'assises de lyon qui le juge depuis
trois jours après avoir déclaré à son
président je n'ai plus l'intention de
continuer à apparaître devant son
tribunal
je suis un citoyen paulinien victime
d'un enlèvement
réponse de l'avocat général barbie en a
le droit il est un nazi sont eux qui
n'osent même pas se pencher sur son
passé et s'expliquer alors qu'ils
regagnaient le fourgon cellulaire barbie
n'a rien dit de plus aux journalistes
qui le pressaient de questions si ce
n'est qu'il n'avait rien à dire
le président hans erni pouvait exiger
qu'il reste dans son box d'accusés
il ne l'a pas fait et le procès
continuera sans barbie
le rodez
klaus barbie sera sans doute une
nouvelle fois absent du box des accusés
cet après midi au moment précis où le
président servi niveau crâne le départ
de lyon en août 1944 du dernier train
vers les camps de la mort puis toutes
les actions de barbie à la gestapo de
lyon entre 42 et 44 seront détaillés
avec toutes les plaintes qui porte sur
les tortures alors gérard beaufils nous
rappelle tous les lieux de lyon qui
garde encore le souvenir tragique de ces
événements opération attila le 11
novembre 1940 de la wehrmacht investi la
zone libre klaus barbie entre dans lion
avec la section 4 du sd le service de
sécurité du reich barbie et ses hommes
de la gestapo s'installe à 50 mètres de
la gare de perrache à l'hôtel terminus
là au troisième étage de cet
établissement 20 chambres sont réservées
aux interrogatoires ils déménagent
avenue berthelot à l'école de santé
militaire au début de 1943 dans ses
caves des milliers de détenus
résistant juif et otages vont subir les
tortures les plus ignobles
pour beaucoup la mort pour les autres la
déportation parvis est bien là pendant
ces séances de même que les témoignages
attestent de sa présence le 9 février au
cours de la rafle de la rue sainte
catherine
le siège de l'union générale des
israélites de france 80 déporté à
auschwitz parmi lesquels le père de
robert badinter ancien garde des sceaux
il n'y aura aucun survivant
place bellecour barbie se promène seul
il a ses habitudes dans un resteront à
deux pas parce qu'un attentat est commis
qu'il fait exécuter cinq otages en
représailles
aujourd'hui un monument rappelle ces
exactions
lorsqu'il ne s'affiche pas avec sa
maîtresse antoinette niro klaus barbie
fréquentes l'immeuble horace cardon rue
mercière où une centaine de filles
pratiquent la collaboration intimes sous
des plafonds l'italienne dans l'immeuble
du 16e siècle
du 22 août 1944 barbie qui pille on part
le dernier train en partance pour
l'allemagne
deux jours plus tard sur les 7000
interne et du fort de montluc les alliés
ne libèreront que 950 survivants madame
monsieur bonsoir les jurés de lyon
devait répondre à trois cent quarante et
une question ils ont répondu oui à 342
ces questions reconnaissant klaus barbie
coupable de dix sept crimes contre
l'humanité ils ont répondu non la
dernière question pas de circonstances
atténuantes pour l'accusé il était 12h40
la nuit dernière lorsque klaus barbie
apprenait thaci du président s'est redit
ni qu'il était condamné à la réclusion à
perpétuité
c'était la fin d'un procès de 52 jours
un procès évidemment historique qui sont
concluait sur une journée très lourde
alors sur les dernières heures du procès
voici gérard beaufils et et mes
meilleurs amis je vous demande qu'à vie
mardi soir qu' lui les neuf jurés de la
cour d'assises du rhône et les trois
magistrats professionnels ont suivi les
réquisitions du procureur général
une circonstance atténuante ont été
retenus barbie n'ira donc ses jours en
prison
ainsi on a décidé hier soir le jury
populaire après six heures et demie de
délibéré je trouve que on vient de
rendre la justice et que barbie a bien
hérité trafford en acier à perpétuité
j'ai beaucoup d'amertume parce qu'il
nous a fallu attendre quarante deux ans
contre cette justice soit rendue en même
temps un soulagement oui parce que j'ai
vu dans la sambre madame allen bonnaire
cette maman de 83 ans passés qui a perdu
des enfants à izieu
je pense que maintenant elle fait sans
aller tranquille la qualité des témoins
directs les victimes directes a été tel
que si on me permet de dire lorsqu on
montrera le film et des dépositions et
bien je le crois que je crois que ce
sera quelque chose peut être supérieure
à chaud
en fin de soirée mouvementée sur les
marches du palais de justice de lyon
après le verdict l'avocat de klaus
barbie quittent les lieux sous les
sifflets et les la dgi de la foule et
quelques manifestants quand même un
moment de s'en prendre à lui le dernier
épisode
inutile de ce procès que l'histoire
retiendra comme exemplaire 37 audience
190 heures de débats des grands et des
petits moments ce qu'ils verront
effectivement la bande vidéo tournée par
ce que l'on appelait les caméras de
l'histoire cela évalueront précisément
le poids de ce procès dans l'histoire
contemporaine
[Musique]